[Musique]
bref non non j'en connais qui lance très
bien et quoi les bons danseurs sont
toujours des poubelles heures par jour
[Applaudissements]
m
l'htc votre avis on est aussi mon époque
1 comment vous l'appelez j'appelle mhd
par son nom de scène mais je sais
travailler ces panneaux lequel je sais
que c'est pas son annonce et yoplait
s'est passé initial c'est quoi son nom
alors mouloud
[Rires]
je te promets b je vais te loue devrais
te promet aussi que je vais être
augmentée ça c'est vrai mon coeur se
prenaient des macros drôle et soe petit
bras déposé dans taloche même si tu les
mange pas oliva j'y crois comme à calais
ils croient comme gilbert est et sort
des emmerdes y est j'y crois qu'au matin
pour mon petit abricots et sétoise
promet une année différente et nouvelle
j'ai tant besoin d'y croire encore merci
à vous merci à johnny mercer
[Applaudissements]